hello and welcome to the new order of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today we have something of an
obscure and deliciously mysterious topic
because i would like to explore one of
if not the greatest lurking legend of
hunter hunter
a man by the name of don freaks no not
gone freaks not jing freaks
but don freaks which might be a very new
and strange name to you
if you're an anime only fan of hunter
hunter because don does not appear in
the events it covered in fact his
existence only becomes known to us in
the manga shortly after the enemy's
conclusion
and actually i should probably say right
here and now that don has not
made a visual appearance in general at
this point he has only ever been
mentioned so i do apologize in advance
for the lack of you know visual material
relating to don freaks over the course
of this video but at the same time the
fact that we haven't seen this guy only
makes him that much more mysterious and
intriguing
especially because we know quite a
surprising amount about him the most
stunning information of which is that
yes
don freaks was a subscriber to the new
order view which granted him regular
hunt on content uploaded straight into
his youtube feed so if you wanted to
become like this man myth and legend all
rolled into one then there is no better
place to start than hitting this
beautiful
crimson red button but in all
seriousness don's existence is first
made known to us in chapter 344 by jing
although some context for what's
happening here because it's important
especially if you're an anime only
watcher
after the events of the anime conclude
we pretty much immediately shift focus
to traveling to the dark continent with
a wide variety of individual groups and
people each gunning for this location
for varying reasons
most of which are still unknown to us at
this stage and jing specifically has
chosen to infiltrate a team of temp
hunters led by a man named beyond
and as such jin begins informing the
team of all sorts of treasures and
horrors that they can expect to find
on the dark continent but how does jing
know all of this information you ask
i mean we do know for a fact that he's
never been to the dark continent himself
well he happens to have read a book
authored by someone who has been to the
dark continent known as
journey to the new world and the author
of this book as you may very well have
guessed by now would
be one don freaks quite the twist out of
nowhere if i do say so myself dropping
in that good old freak's name but this
story still has yet to become truly
strange because journey to the new world
does not exist as a single time
and instead is divided into two parts
being the east and west editions
respectively and from here i'm going to
defer to the words of jing freaks to
best explain the existence of these
books
there are idiots in any era in fact
there was one guy who tried to explore
the entire mobius shoreline by himself
300 years ago he even wrote a book about
it journey to the new world east
and west editions but only the east has
been found with no sign of the west
and as for why this is there are three
possible reasons i can think of
one is that it simply hasn't been found
yet another is that the author's goal
was too ambitious
and he never wrote it and the third is
that he's still writing as we speak
and that book's author is don freaks and
just
like that we have created one of the
most fascinating characters to have ever
existed in this brilliant series
although i do think we need to take a
moment to explain some things here
because there may be certain features
that don't quite add up initially
such as the idea that don if he is
indeed alive would be well over 300
years old at this point
which can be quite an alarming thought
because aging in hunter hunter more or
less reflects that of reality with the
exception of very well-versed nen users
masters of this art form can conserve
and even apply the aura directly to slow
the aging process
or to preserve the body for as long as
possible but even that has its limits a
good example of which would be isaac
netara while we have never discovered
his exact age netro is at least 110
years old and from that it can also be
inferred that his contemporaries such as
the neodyrev and mahazodik would share a
similar age range and whilst they could
fast surpass that 110 years netro at the
very least should not even come close to
reaching 300 and we know this because it
has been stated that netro was 50 years
old when he completed the whole punching
ritual in less than an hour and it has
also been said that he descended from
the mountains roughly
60 years before his death so i suppose
netro could have remained in the
mountains for close to
you know 200 years but it is highly
unlikely and as such this would make don
freaks theoretically far
and away the oldest known character in
hunter which is very very possible
because don does have one key advantage
that netro would not have when it comes
to aging and that is being a resident of
the dark continent because don would
have had access to a substance known as
nitro rice which is said to be the
ultimate secret to longevity and in fact
a whole expedition to the dark continent
was conducted in search of this
substance by the federation of ochima an
unsuccessful expedition that is that
fell prey to the calamity of hellbell
but the very existence of nitro rice
demonstrates the possibility of
effective immortality but the thing is
it doesn't even need to be nitro rice
specifically that's just
what we know of currently the dark
continent is full of substances that can
grant humanity powers and benefits
far beyond the wildest imagination of
what is available in the human realm and
what i also find quite interesting is
the possibility that don freaks actually
predates the entire hunter association
because their current exam year would be
289 making them very very old but not
quite as old as the life mission of don
freaks but don being over 300 years old
is oddly enough quite possibly the
easiest thing to accept about this man
a much more difficult thought is how one
man has survived the dark continent for
this song
or indeed at all and to demonstrate the
difficulty of this endeavor we need look
no further than once again isaac netaro
whose brief flashback gives us the only
true glimpse of the sand mass that we've
been privy to at this point
and even he was completely overwhelmed
by the power of this continent having
stated that the only possible victory
that could be obtained here was survival
itself and whilst netro and don have
quite clearly achieved that victory one
more so than the other this is not true
of the other known expeditions as other
voyages have universally resulted in
utter utter failure
and mass casualties and i really don't
think that the power of this continent
can be overstated to take a well-known
example the chimera ants were native to
the dark continent and exposing them to
the cosy realm of humanity almost
resulted in the extinction of mankind
within a mere couple of months
meanwhile it has also been confirmed
that nanika is a creature from the dark
continent as well who is quite literally
the most powerful character within
the entire series capable of essentially
anything so long
as it is in wish form plus we do have
the five calamities one of which may be
nanaka actually but look whether it be
flora or fauna
each and every living thing on the dark
continent seems to be capable
of wiping out humanity let alone a
single human
exploring its home territory and make no
mistake these beings also possess a
great threat to nen users as well as the
general public obviously and even though
you could argue that the chimera ants
only became an apocalyptic level threat
because they discovered nen
in the end marom's colony was only
designated as a class
b threat and just let that sink in for a
moment meruem and his entire colony
did not even warrant the highest threat
ranking so there's some pretty damn
serious stuff out there all of which don
freaks to have even completed the first
half of his book
would have needed to either combat or
avoid and i think it would be pretty
foolish to assume that he did not use
nen to do so however another very
interesting thing about don is that he
would predate the shingen ryu school of
kung fu by
almost 250 years which is the primary
institution that developed the general
practices of nen as we know it and while
it's obviously possible to become a nen
master through other avenues it's
interesting to think about the fact that
don friggs may be invoking a very
old and perhaps even lost methodology of
wielding aura and the other option is of
course that don may be an unconscious
end user one of the very rare people who
are able to activate and wield their
aura without realizing what they're
doing which is usually a pretty
startlingly powerful use of men think
komugi who was able to invoke her aura
for the purpose of playing gungi and
never lost once to the
impossible genius of marowan if anything
this kind of aura usage is usually far
more potent than consciously sculpted in
abilities and something like that could
very much explain don's highly
highly improbable survival and just a
quick note on don's mission here i often
see the misconception that he set out to
explore the entirety of the dark
continent which i would say would be
next to impossible because
it's simply too big it would probably
take tens of thousands of years to do so
probably more so don weirdly enough has
a more abridged goal of sorts being that
he made it his mission to travel around
the shoreline of lake mobius
lake mobius being the giant stretch of
water in the middle in which the human
realm actually resides
so that's right the entirety of the
human world in hunter
is actually more like a tiny speck of
island thing in this
truly massive lake nestled inside of an
even more truly
massive continent and now something else
i should address is that while jing has
obviously read the east edition of
journey to the new world this does not
appear to be common knowledge amongst
the hunter association and this is
probably because this manuscript was
actually widely considered to be a work
of fiction
up until recent times anyway and
currently the east edition is housed in
a very highly secure facility by the v6
which are an alliance of six of the
human world's most vast and powerful
countries and whilst copies of this book
do exist they are not widespread and are
mostly given to agents of the v6 who are
charged with handling dark
continent-related activities
such poor poor unfortunate people they
are and the one other thing we haven't
discussed up until this point would be
the name of freaks which would obviously
heavily imply that don
is related to both gon and jing and i
mean look it's technically unconfirmed
but i would be
pretty beyond shocked if this was not
the case and i think it's currently
sliding in quite nicely with the general
themes of hunter hunter and what i mean
by that is that for the most part of the
series we follow gone around the realm
of humanity
in search of his legendary father jing
and now that that mission is wrapped
up we're taking it a step further by
following jing around the new world
in search of a long-lost relative in don
it's almost too perfect and in some kind
of glorious
fantasy world where hunter hunter was
published regularly oh
just imagine that maybe even one day we
could discover that gone was simply a
freaks in search of yet another
legendary freaks
this time thousands of years old and
just keep this cycle going although
another nice idea does exist because
most of this video does assume that don
is alive because that would be the most
tantalizing thought to grasp onto
however that may be far from the case
and there's also the potential that this
entire story is being set up for jing to
discover don
or what remains of don and then perhaps
finish his relatives work by concluding
the west edition of journey to the new
world but whatever the case the very
idea
that don freaks does or at least did
exist opens up a whole new world of
hunter hunter alongside the dark
continent itself and don is a very
important anchor in this entire concept
because it's one thing to unveil this
mysterious landmass with the promise of
horrors and discovery but what makes
this idea
infinitely more interesting is the fact
that there is at least one person who
has against all odds managed to either
conquer or
integrate into that ecosystem a feat
that not even the great isaac netaro was
capable of and so as it is don freaks
may very well represent a new pinnacle
of humanity in terms of power
intelligence and sheer will to survive
and thrive and regardless of whether he
is still with us or not he is an
undeniably legendary figure of hunter
hunter but what do you guys think please
do leave your thoughts in the comments
below or even join my discord server and
if you're keen for some more hunt hunter
content then please do feel free to
check out some of my other videos or
even subscribe to the channel for
regular hunt on to glory delivered
straight
into your youtube feed but for now this
has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time